(gasps)
- What is that?
(crying softly)
(uneasy music)
- [Daniel Myrick] One of the
best ways to watch the film
is alone on a crappy VHS
or some old DVD player.
Ed and I both knew that we wanted the film
to feel like a documentary.
We shot the film chronologically.
We had way points guided by GPS
so they could navigate through the woods
without being kind of hindered by a crew.
We shadowed them as they were
moving through the trees.
- [Eduardo Sanchez] Dan
and I kept away from them
as much as possible.
- [Dan] And there would be a bicycle flag,
so when they got into the
general area of their way point
that's on their GPS,
they could see the flag.
So that's when they were
instructed to pitch a tent.
This is where you're
camping for the night.
We had those plastic milk crates,
and inside would be food stuffs,
fresh batteries for the cameras,
film for the film camera,
and then there would be these
old school film canisters,
and inside those little plastic containers
would be directing notes.
And they were all instructed
to not read each other's notes.
So we set up this
conflict, but we allow them
to choose the time when
they want to have it.
The mandate was just
to roll on everything.
The name of the scene in the
script, The Confessional,
it was the moment in the film
where it stopped being a
project about the Blair Witch
and started being a chronicling
of their last days on Earth.
- [Eduardo] We were directing the actors
like their conscience speaking to them.
For Heather, it was like,
"You're responsible for this.
"Say your goodbyes.
"Turn the camera light on and
point the camera at your face.
"Just give us everything you've got."
- [Dan] She took the camera
and walked off by herself
and just had this monologue
to end all monologues.
- There was a lot more snot.
There was rivers and rivers of snot.
We wanted to strike a balance
between the performance
and not getting too
distracted with the snot flow.
- [Eduardo] But I remember
first seeing that monologue,
and our jaws dropped.
And I think that was the
moment where we were like,
"Wow, this really could work
if we don't screw it up."
We knew it was something special.
And we kind of made this
little bit of film history.
(intense music)